other big story tonight we now know when
all clark county school district
district students will likely return to
the classroom and begin
hybrid learning we've got team coverage
from both the classroom
and the ball fields we begin with 8 news
now reporter
kristen drummond superintendent dr jesus
jar revealing the opening plans for all
grade levels at peterson elementary
school on wednesday
the timeline gets secondary students
back in classrooms before the end of the
school year
this is something that we have been
agonizing
for a long time to get our kids
in front of our teachers dr jarrah
making the announcement as elementary
schools prepare for some
pre-kindergarten to third grade students
starting hybrid learning monday
other grade levels will soon follow that
model in the district's proposed
timeline
i tell you our staff has been
finding ways to get this done on march
1st lower elementary students will start
hybrid learning
then on march 15th all ccsd employees
are expected back in buildings
march 22nd grades 6 9 and 12 can return
to
in-person learning under the hybrid
model grades
7 8 10 and 11 will start hybrid on
april 6 after spring break also on april
6th
pre-k through grade 5 likely returns to
five days a week
in person learning dr jarrar says the
state easing school reopening
restrictions last week
helped speed up the process he adds the
district chose
6th 9th and 12th grades first for a
reason you look at our 6th graders that
have not been in a school
in their middle schools all year and our
high school
9th graders as well it was an
opportunity for us to get our kids in
for a week
to transition into our middle schools in
high school before our upperclassmen
showed up
dr jarros says full-time distance
education remains an option for families
and will be
after this school year reporting in las
vegas kristin drummond
8 news now